N
THE ELECTION.
FIRST WE DO BEGIN WITH A WARNING
FROM THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
ONCE THE EPICENTER FROM THE
AMERICAN DREAM.
BEAUTIFUL NATURAL RESOURCES,
BEAUTIFUL LANDSCAPES, INCREDIBLE
WEATHER.
FREETHINKING ENTREPRENEURS.
THE LAND OF RONALD REAGAN.
IT'S BEEN UTTERLY RUINED BY
DEMOCRATS WHO LIVE THERE AND
THERE DEMOCRATIC ELECTED
OFFICIALS.
THEY HAVE LITERALLY RUN THE
STATE INTO THE GROUND AND NOW
ARE CHASING PEOPLE AWAY.
AMERICANS ARE NOW FLEEING THAT
STATE IN DROVES.
A NUMBER OF VERY SERIOUS ISSUES.
THE LAWLESSNESS, THE CRIME,
VIOLENT CRIME, HIGH TAXES
SUFFOCATING REGULATION.
EACH OF THE LAST TWO YEARS
CALIFORNIA HAS WITNESSED THE
POPULATION DECLINE.
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME THAT HAS
EVER HAPPENED IN OVER 170 YEARS.
TONIGHT WE ARE GOING TO FOCUS ON
ONE OF THE MOST PRESSING ISSUES
IN THE GOLDEN STATE THAT IS
THEIR MASSIVE ENERGY CRISIS
GOING ON RIGHT NOW TODAY.
THIS WEEK FROM THE COMFORT OF
HIS OWN VERY WELL
AIR-CONDITIONED HOME, HE'S EVEN
WEARING LONG SLEEVES AND
EVERYTHING.
FAR LEFT SOCIALIST
GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM DONNED A
WARM FLEECE JACKET DEMANDING
THAT OTHER CALIFORNIANS TURN
DOWN THEIR THERMOSTATS, TURN
THEIR LIGHTS OFF.
MY FAVORITE PART IS YOU MUST
REFRAIN FROM CHARGING YOUR
ELECTRIC VEHICLE THE COST YOU
$20,000 MORE THAN A GAS POWERED
VEHICLE BECAUSE THE STATE'S
POWER GRID IS TOTALLY
COLLAPSING.
FROM A STATE THAT JUST BAN THE
SALE OF GAS POWERED CARS BY
2035.
MEANWHILE, THE DEMOCRATIC HACK
ERIC SWALWELL ECHO THE
GOVERNOR'S DESPERATE PLEAS
TWEETING "IT'S TIME TO RALLY,
CALIFORNIA.
WE ALL NEED TO DO OUR PART TO
HELP AVOID POWER OUTAGES THIS
WEEK.
BEFORE 4:00 P.M., PREQUEL YOUR
HOME.
I'M SURE THAT WILL LAST ALL
THROUGH THE NIGHT.
AFTER 4:00 P.M., AVOID THE USE
OF MAJOR APPLIANCES.
I DON'T KNOW.
MAYBE KUKLA FRIED EGG OUTSIDE.
MAYBE THE CEMENT.
WHO KNOWS.
TURN YOUR THERMOSTAT TO 78 OR
HIGHER.
LET'S KEEP THE LIGHTS ON,
CALIFORNIA.
YOU CAN'T MAKE THIS UP.
THIS ENERGY RATIONING AND THE
FORTHCOMING POTENTIAL
BLACKOUT-BROWNOUT IS THE DIRECT
RESULT OF THE STATES CLIMATE
HYSTERIA.
LAWMAKERS HAVE ALREADY SHUT DOWN
75% OF THE STATES NUCLEAR POWER
PLANTS.
WHAT DO YOU EXPECT?
THEY ARE OF MENDING A PLAN TO
PHASE OUT ALL OIL AND GAS
PRODUCTION BY 2045.
THEY'VE ALREADY BANNED FRACKING.
THEY BANNED GAS POWERED
LAWN MOWERS.
THEY BANNED GAS POWERED LEAF
BLOWERS.
OF COURSE THEY PUMPED BILLIONS
AND BILLIONS OF WASTED DOLLARS
TO INEFFICIENT SOLAR PANELS,
WIND TURBINES, HYDROELECTRIC
DAMS IN AREAS FACING LONG-TERM
DROUGHTS.
IT'S TURNED OUT TO BE AN
UNMITIGATED DISASTER.
THE RESULT, THE STATE WITH THE
MOST NATURAL RESOURCES IN THE
COUNTRY IS NOW RELYING ON OTHER
STATE AND THE COUNTRY OF MEXICO
TO SUPPORT THEIR VERY OWN POWER
GRID THAT THEY ARE STILL SHORT
ON POWER OF.
BY THE WAY, IMPORTING MORE THAN
30% OF THE ENERGY NEEDS AND
THAT'S STILL NOT ENOUGH.
BY THE WAY, DESPITE ALL THESE
MEASURES, THE STATES.
HE STILL OVERWHELMINGLY
COMPRISED OF NATURAL GAS.
EUROPE EXPORTED ITS ENERGY NEEDS
TO RUSSIA.
THEY ARE IMPORTING IT FROM
RUSSIA.
PUTIN JUST SHUT DOWN THE NORD
STREAM ! PIPELINE.
HOUSEHOLDS SAW AUGUST BILLS JUMP
AN AVERAGE 185% COMPARED WITH
ONE YEAR EARLIER.
COME WINTER, THIS INSANE SPIKE
IS EXPECTED TO GET SO MUCH
WORSE, EUROPEAN FAMILIES ARE
SPENDING 20 OR 30% OF THEIR
ENTIRE INCOME ON MONTHLY HEATING
BILLS ALONE.
DEPENDING ON FOREIGN COUNTRIES,
HUGE PRICE INCREASES, ENERGY
RATIONING, ROLLING BLACKOUTS,
BROWNOUTS, NO AIR CONDITIONING,
NO HEAT, ELECTRIC CARS DO NOT
EVEN ALLOWED TO PLUG-IN.
THOSE EXPENSIVE ELECTRIC
VEHICLES ARE POWERED BY FOSSIL
FUELS.
THAT IS THE EUROPEAN MODEL.
THIS IS THE CALIFORNIA MODEL.
THIS IS THE FUTURE THAT
DEMOCRATS WANT FOR YOU.
BUT DON'T TAKE MY WORD FOR IT.
JUST LISTEN TO BIDEN'S ENERGY
SECRETARY.
>> CALIFORNIA IS IN THE LEAD, IT
CAN SHOW THE REST OF THE NATION
HOW IT'S DONE.
>> WOW.
WHEN ASKED IF BIDEN AGREES WITH
THIS ENERGY SECRETARY,
KARINE JEAN-PIERRE WAS UNABLE TO
ANSWER THE QUESTION.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> LAST FRIDAY THE ENERGY
SECRETARY SAID OF GREEN
TECHNOLOGY IN CALIFORNIA THAT
THAT STATE WAS IN THE LEAD IN
SHOWING THE REST OF THE NATION
HOW IT'S DONE.
THE STATE IS CURRENTLY BRACING
FOR BLACKOUTS.
THEY SET AMBITIOUS GOALS.
THERE GOVERNOR IS ASKING FOLKS
NOT TO CHARGE THEIR ELECTRIC
VEHICLES.
DOES THE PRESIDENT AGREE
CALIFORNIA IS AN EXAMPLE FOR THE
REST OF THE COUNTRY?
>> I HAVEN'T SEEN THE SPECIFIC
STATEMENTS.
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE IT IN FULLER
CONTEXT.
NOT GOING TO COMMENT ON
SOMETHING I HAVEN'T SEEN IN
FULL.
>> Sean: GREEN ENERGY AND
CLIMATE ALARMISM, THAT'S THE
CENTERPIECE OF BIDEN'S ARE
HORRIFIC AGENDA AND THE ENERGY
GRID IN CALIFORNIA IS IMPLODING.
SOME RESIDENTS HAVE BEEN
PICTURED ALLEGEDLY CHANGING
THEIR TESLAS AND CHARGING THEM
WITH GAS POWERED GENERATORS.
THAT'S MY FAVORITE PICTURE.
YOU HAVE AN ELECTRIC VEHICLE BUT
YOU'RE USING A GAS POWERED
GENERATOR TO CHARGE IT UP.
WHITE HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY
CAN'T BE BOTHERED TO FAMILIARIZE
HERSELF WITH THE ISSUE AND YOU
MAY HAVE NOTICED DEMOCRATS DON'T
REALLY CARE ABOUT THE QUALITY OF
YOUR LIFE.
IT'S PRETTY OBVIOUS THAT THEY
HATE YOU, ESPECIALLY IF YOU HAVE
OR HAVE EVER SUPPORTED
DONALD TRUMP SO NOW THEY WANT TO
TAKE YOUR INDIVIDUAL POWER.
THEY WANT YOU TO TRANSITION OR
ACCEPT THEIR TRANSITION EVEN
THOUGH THEY DON'T HAVE THE
TECHNOLOGY.
GREEN ENERGY RENEWABLES THAT
THEY KEEP SAYING WERE GOING TO
BECOME ENERGY DEPENDENT ON IS
NOT AVAILABLE.
SO THEY'RE GOING TO FOLLOW THE
FAILED EUROPEAN STYLE SOCIALIST
HEALTH SCAPE WHERE YOU OWE
NOTHING, CONTROL NOTHING, AND
SIMPLY LIVE TO EXIST WHILE A
RULING CLASS IS MAKING EVERY
DECISION FOR YOU.
THEN WERE GOING TO
TAKE ALL THE POWER AND WE ARE
GOING TO MAKE COUNTRIES LIKE
RUSSIA, IRAN, VENEZUELA,
SAUDI ARABIA, OPEC NATIONS RICH
AGAIN.
THIS OBSESSION WITH GREEN ENERGY
IS REALLY ALSO ABOUT SOCIALISM
AND ITS AFFRONT ON ALL THINGS
SOCIALISM BECAUSE IF THEY REALLY
CARED ABOUT THE ENVIRONMENT WE
WOULD BE PRODUCING ALL OF OUR
OIL, ALL OF OUR GAS, ALL OF OUR
CALL RIGHT HERE AT HOME.
GUESS WHAT.
WE WOULD DO IT FASTER, CHEAPER,
CLEANER.
IMPORTING ON MASSIVE SHIPS FROM
THE MIDDLE EAST OR VENEZUELA OR
RUSSIA OR CHINA OR IRAN, WELL,
WHY WOULD WE WANT TO MAKE THE
IRANIAN MULLAHS RICH AGAIN?
CAUSES HARM TO THE ENVIRONMENT
AND MAKES HOSTILE REGIMES FILTHY
RICH.
WE SHOULD BECOME ENERGY DOMINANT
AND HELP OUR EUROPEAN ALLIES
OUT, AND WE BECOME FILTHY RICH.
MAYBE NOT EVEN HAVE TO PAY
TAXES.
IF THE LEFT ACTUALLY CARED ABOUT
THE ENVIRONMENT, THEY WOULD BE
HONEST ABOUT THE ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACT OF ELECTRIC CARS.
CHARGE BY OUR OWN POWER GRID, BY
FOSSIL FUELS THAT RELY ON
BATTERIES COMPRISED OF RARE
EARTH MINERALS AND MATERIALS
MIND WITH HEAVY DIESEL EQUIPMENT
IN FOREIGN COUNTRIES, HOME TO A
FEW IF ANY ENVIRONMENTAL
REGULATIONS.
THEY DON'T TELL YOU THAT PART.
IF BIDEN CARED ABOUT THE
ENVIRONMENT, HE WOULDN'T BE
DRAINING AMERICA'S STRATEGIC
PETROLEUM RESERVES.
NOW AT 37 YEAR LOW.
HOW DID WE GET TO A 37 YEAR LOW?
HE GAVE 1 MILLION BARRELS OF OIL
HE SOLD TO THE CHINESE.
NOT SURE WHY.
MOSTLY IT WAS USED AS A PLOY TO
TEMPORARILY LOWER GAS PRICES,
ARTIFICIALLY LOWER GAS PRICES,
JUST BEFORE THE ELECTION, TO
MAKE YOU THINK GAS PRICES WERE
GOING DOWN ON THE MARKET WAS
BECOMING MORE STABLE.
THAT'S A PLOY THAT IS BEYOND
SINISTER BECAUSE IT'S DANGEROUS
TO OUR NATIONAL SECURITY.
DEMOCRATS ARE NOT BEING HONEST,
AS USUAL.
THEIR POLICIES WILL NOT MAKE
YOUR LIFE ANY BETTER IN ANY WAY.
THIS IS NOT SPECULATION.
WE ARE IN REAL TIME AFTER
DECADES OF ONE-PARTY DEMOCRATIC
RULE IN PLACES LIKE CALIFORNIA,
LIKE NEW YORK, LIKE BALTIMORE,
LIKE PHILADELPHIA.
LIKE CHICAGO.
THE STANDARD OF LIVING ALWAYS
GOES DOWN.
THROUGH NEARLY TWO YEARS OF
JOE BIDEN, WELL, GUESS WHAT.
A EVERY AMERICAN IS PAYING MORE
FOR GAS TO FILL UP THEIR CARS.
PAYING MORE TO HEAT AND COOL
THEIR HOME